round five of the London chess classic  the last stop on the grand chest or with  the resume on tap the players came in  determined to give it their all to move  up the leaderboard five-time world  champion Viswanathan Anand played a  spectacular novelty against tournament  leader Wesley so and brought about a  solid draw without much effort the  surging Hikaru Nakamura threw the  kitchen sink at former champion vladimir  kramnik but the world number three shut  the door with incredibly precise defense  and left both players still only tied  for second place that left England's  Michael Adams who defeated the hapless  Vasily topalov in dominating fashion  much to the delight of the British crowd  the players have had a day to relax and  it's time for a second half of fighting  chest round six of the season-ending  plastic starts right now  [Music]